He may have been a major player in the pages
of Marvel Comics for over half a century,
but it was only recently that Captain America
became the poster boy for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
The quintessential hero, it’s almost impossible
to imagine what kind of fight would force
him to turn against his fellow Avengers.
But you might be surprised to find out that
the comic book history of the squeaky clean,
star spangled Boy Scout is as dark as they
come.
And if fans of comic book movies think their
superhero blockbusters are getting a little
too dark, violent, or serious, they’d better
hope these famous moments from Captain America’s
history are never adapted.
But they’re still stories every fan should
know, so we’ve made them the focus of our
latest Docu Series: The Shockingly DARK History
of Captain America.
The Original Captain America
Looking back now, it makes perfect sense for
Cap to have made his debut in a solo comic,
punching out Adolf Hitler on the front cover.
But remember: the first comic was released
in 1941, a full year before the United States
even entered World War 2.
So to a large part of the American public
who weren’t looking to go to war with Germany,
the star-spangled hero made his debut knocking
a foreign head of state unconscious.
The move proved controversial, since the world
didn’t know just what Hitler’s Third Reich
was up to, but it didn’t stop Timely Comics,
the original publishers, since the comics
that followed were huge successes, showing
Cap knocking out Nazis of all shapes and sizes.
The stories inside the comics were a bit different,
but remember: Steve Rogers and his sidekick
Bucky Barnes were American soldiers first
– so while DC’s Batman was snapping criminals’
necks, Cap and Bucky were wiping out Nazi
soldiers one grenade at a time.
It was war, sure, but that didn’t stop Marvel
from rewriting history years later to keep
Cap’s killing to a minimum.
Captain America Goes To Hell
Things got weird with Captain America almost
immediately.
Once the war came to an end, the writers had
to find a new purpose for Cap – and had
serious trouble doing it.
After just 70 issues, Cap and his famous enemy
Red Skull had fought in so many weird places,
there was just one left to go: Hell.
Descending into the underworld in “Captain
America’s Weird Tales” and forced to kill
Red Skull or remain there for God, Cap came
through, unsure if it was all a dream – or
completely real.
Not surprising, it was the final issue he
would appear in before joining plenty of his
fellow superheroes on the shelf.
Reference: http://fourcolorshadows.blogspot.ca/2012/03/red-skull-strikes-again-captain.html
Captain America: Commie Smasher
It wasn’t long before a new political crisis
seemed perfect for Captain America: the red
menace, also known as Communism spreading
around the globe.
The paranoia of the 1950s is usually remembered
as a mistake, and Captain America shows why:
returning as “Captain America: Commie Smasher,”
there was no actual threat or enemy for Cap
to fight.
So weird Soviet monsters, or Southeast Asian
villains were created in hopes they could
drum up the same patriotic excitement as a
decade before.
They didn’t, and the obvious racism and
bigotry in Cap and Bucky battling people based
on their politics or ethnicity seemed to prove
that his time had passed.
Or, a new mission was needed, at least.
Captain America: The Murderer
We know what you’re thinking: if Steve Roger
was frozen in the 1940s, how could he have
been smashing Commies a decade later?
That’s a question that Stan Lee ignored
completely, even though he wrote the stories
in question.
In 1964, Lee locked Cap’s origin in for
good, having been frozen, and thawed out by
the Avengers years later.
It was here that Steve’s Super-Soldier procedure
was completely fleshed out, with Lee confirming
one detail that seems pretty important in
hindsight.
That German spy who killed the brilliant scientist
behind the serum?
Steve killed him almost immediately.
Brutally beating him and throwing him into
running machinery.
But don’t worry: things are about to get
even stranger for Cap fans…
Captain America vs. Captain America
It wasn’t until the 1970s that Marvel finally
explained the plot hole of Cap operating in
the 1950s, but instead of wiping them out
of continuity, they took an even crazier path.
The Cap of the 1950s was an imposter, having
undergone plastic surgery to look the part,
and injecting himself – and his sidekick
– with a reverse-engineered serum that was
slowly driving them insane.
Not weird enough?
The imposter, now the villain known as The
Grand Director hatched a plan that saw him
pose as Steve Rogers leading a wave of neo
Nazis in Harlem, splattering a swastika across
his famous shield.
Daredevil eventually helped save the day,
but things for the hero were only going to
get weirder, and darker.
Captain America Quits
As the Watergate scandal and Richard Nixon’s
resignation were going on in real life, it
only made sense for Captain America to reflect
the loss of faith in government – with some
comic book flair, of course.
In the comics, Cap fought a Secret Empire
conspiracy of his own, eventually catching
its leader to realize… well, it was basically
Richard Nixon.
Not dark enough?
Okay, the implied president shot himself to
death in the next panel.
As disillusioned as millions of Americans,
Cap turned in his uniform for good.
Well, a few weeks at least.
Captain America Quits…
Again
The Civil War story wasn’t the first time
that Cap was asked to become an official operative
of the government, and the first time, his
choice was simple.
Deciding he represented the American people,
not the military or government, Steve Rogers
resigned, with the authorities turning to
an unlikely replacement: John Walker, formerly
known as the Super Patriot, a former enemy
of Cap’s.
More aggressive, more racially intolerant,
and less heroic, Walker even picked one of
his immigrant-hating sidekicks as his new
Bucky.
But he eventually proved he really wasn’t
cut out for so heroic a role, when he beat
a supervillain to death with his bare hands.
Civil War & The Death of Captain America
The Civil War between Cap and Iron Man playing
out on the big screen is a bit different than
in the comics, when Steve and Tony Stark were
split on a major issue.
Where Tony figured every superhuman should
give up their privacy, Steve saw it as the
government overstepping their rights.
The bloody battle that followed answered the
question of who would win, but Cap ended up
surrendering anyway.
He even faced his charges and sentence willingly,
but never got to serve them, getting a stomach
full of bullets on the steps of the courthouse.
It’s as good and dark a death as any superhero
could hope for, but just like the others,
it didn’t last for long…
So what do you think?
Should these dark chapters of Captain America’s
history be brought to the big screen?
Or are they better left forgotten?
Are there any dark stories of your own favorite
superheroes that have these ones beat?
Let us know in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one.